Look at this picture.
And let's look at the probability first.
We said that the definition of probability.
is
The Chosen number of outcomes plus the
total number of possible outcomes
suppose you have
marbles
Four of them are blue.
six of them are yellow
What is the probability of getting a Blue Marble?
You put your hand into a jar. What is a probability that if
you put your hand into this jar of mixed of
marbles with mixed colors, what is it? Probably
of it turning blue?
That will be four.
over 10
right
same thing with the coins or something with a coin.
if you flip a coin
Which I which obviously has two faces. What is
there? Probably that you would get a particular face.
1 over 2 you have two possible outcomes.
And your chosen outcome is one.
So what we do is we compare.
The Chosen number of outcomes over the total possible number total possible
number of outcomes
now odds
is the ratio
of
one
chose set of chosen outcomes versus another set
of chosen outcomes.
Or set differently it is it is
the ratio of one event.
over another event
and basically if the odds if we
evaluate this quantity.
and the number is greater than 1
then the odds are in favor of the event in the numerator.
If the number Falls below one, then the odds are in favor of
the event in the denominator.
And obviously if odds is equal to 1 that means
both of them are.
They have this their equivalent.
So we have a one-to-one ratio.
Both of them have equal probability. So 50%
50% this 50% down.
If you look at this picture.
Obviously if you were to evaluate this if we would have
four divided by 6.
This quantity would be below 1.
So the odds would be in favor of the denominator.
Obviously right when we if we have more golden marbles than
if you were to put your hand into the jar, you're more likely
or the probability is greater that you would get a
golden a gold model versus a Blue Marble.
So odds one event over
another event.
Now likelihood is an extension of odds.
The difference is likelihood is the ratio of
two conditional probabilities.
a given B
over for example a given C
same idea
Okay.
Now, let's go back to the other document.